aller guten dinge sind drei ist heute
das motto denn verteidigungsministerin
klaudia tanner und öbb generaldirektor
andreas matthä taufen am donnerstag die
dritte öbb login bh luke die beiden
kooperationspartner bundesbahnen und
bundesheer betonen die harmonie in ihrer
zusammenarbeit für österreich was es
unbedingt zu erhalten gilt ist die
zusammenarbeit die den übergang die
interoperabilität es so schön heißt
zwischen system bahn und militär um im
notfall unserer bevölkerung schutz
mobilität und hilfe zukommen zu lassen
und hier haben wir in unserer
schnittmenge ein stückweit gemeinsame
gesellschaftspolitische verantwortung
für verteidigungsministerin klaudia
tanner ist die zusammenarbeit mit den
öbb vor allem auch geprägt von einem
ganz besonderen er vertrauen von einer
engen zusammenarbeit der general
director seien schon angesprochen zum
wohle der österreichischen bevölkerung
und aus diesen vertrauten miteinander
ist ein neues unter ich dafür sagen
wirklich sehr kreatives projekt auch
entstanden nämlich diese beeindruckende
lockt die in zukunft mit ihren 10.000 ps
bis zu 230 km h schnell in ganz
österreich unterwegs sein wird
diese ist ab jetzt schon lieblings
locker des österreichischen bundesheeres
zeigt er nicht nur unser motto geschützt
in österreich sondern auch die
vielfältigen aufgaben die das
österreichische bundesheer zu öffnen hat
gerade auch in zeiten von caron
das ist ein unglaublicher werbewert dem
wir jetzt viele zugreisende sicher
transportiert werden das aufhören
das sind wirklich